Traductor: Yoshinori Casas
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
En el verano de 1997,
la nave "Pathfinder" de la NASA
descendió en la superficie de Marte,
e increíblemente transmitió
imágenes icónicas a la Tierra.
Después de algunos días,
ocurrió algo terrible.
Las transmisiones se detuvieron.
El "Pathfinder" de hecho
estaba procrastinando:
manteniéndose ocupado sin hacer
su trabajo más importante.
¿Qué estaba sucediendo?
Resulta ser que había un error
de programación en el planificador.
Cada sistema operativo
tiene algo llamado el planificador
que le dice a la CPU cuánto tiempo
trabajar en una tarea antes de cambiar,
y a qué cambiar.
Hecho adecuadamente, los computadores
cambian las tareas de forma fluida,
dando la ilusión de que hacen
todo simultáneamente.
Pero todos sabemos lo que sucede
cuando las cosas salen mal.
Esto debería darnos algo de consuelo.
Incluso los computadores
son abrumados algunas veces.
Posiblemente aprender la ciencia
de la planificación informática
puede darnos una idea de cómo
los humanos luchamos con el tiempo.
Una de las primeras ideas es que el tiempo
gastado en priorizar el trabajo
es tiempo que no se gasta haciéndolo.
Por ejemplo, al revisar el email,
echar un vistazo a todos los mensajes,
para elegir cuál es el más importante.
Una vez resuelto el correo,
repite la tarea.
Parece sensato, pero hay un problema.
Esto se llama un algoritmo
de tiempo cuadrático.
Con una bandeja el doble de llena,
estos pasos toman el doble de tiempo
y necesitarás hacer el doble de trabajo.
Es decir 4 veces el mismo trabajo.
Los programadores
del sistema operativo Linux
encontraron un problema
similar en el 2003.
Linux organizaba todas las tareas
en orden de importancia,
y algunas veces gastaba más tiempo
organizándolas que ejecutándolas.
La solución de los programadores
fue reemplazar la organización
con un número limitado
de grupos prioritarios.
El sistema era menos preciso
en qué hacer a continuación
pero recuperaba con creces
el tiempo ejecutando tareas.
Entonces con la bandeja, hacer
la tarea más importante primero
podría llevar a un colapso.
Al encontrar una bandeja llena
3 veces más de lo normal
podría llevar 9 veces más tiempo limpiarla.
¡Sería mejor responderlos en orden
cronológico o incluso aleatoriamente!
Sorprendentemente, dejar
de hacer cosas en orden perfecto
puede ser la clave para terminarlas.
Otra idea que emerge
de la programación computacional
tiene que ver con una característica
de la vida moderna: la interrupción.
Cuando un computador
cambia de una tarea a otra,
tiene que hacer un cambio de contexto,
marcar su lugar en una tarea,
mover los datos antiguos
de la memoria y traer nuevos datos.
Cada acción tiene un costo.
La idea es que hay
un intercambio fundamental
entre productividad
y capacidad de respuesta.
Hacer un trabajo serio significa
minimizar cambios de contexto.
Pero responder significa reaccionar
cada vez que algo sucede.
Estos dos principios son
fundamentalmente opuestos.
Reconocer esta oposición permite
decidir donde atacar ese balance.
La solución obvia es minimizar
las interrupciones.
La menos obvia es agruparlas.
Si ninguna notificación o email
requiere una respuesta
en menos de una hora, digamos,
entonces esa es la frecuencia
para revisarlos. No más.
En la informática, esta idea
se llama interrupción moderada.
en lugar de lidiar con las cosas
a medida que surgen
-- ¿Se movió el ratón?
¿Una tecla fue presionada?
¿Más archivos descargados? --
el sistema agrupa estas interrupciones
basado en cuánto tiempo pueden esperar.
En 2013, la interrupción moderada
incrementó la vida de la batería
de los computadores portátiles.
Porque aplazar interrupciones permite
que el sistema revise todo a la vez,
y luego entrar en estado
de bajo consumo de energía.
Al igual que con los computadores,
también lo es con nosotros.
Tal vez adoptar un enfoque similar
puede permitirnos como usuarios
recuperar nuestra atención,
y recuperar una de las cosas que parece
extraña en la vida moderna: el descanso.